the five most common symptoms associated
with the omicron variant include runny
nose fatigue which can be mild or severe
headache sore throat as well as sneezing
however there are other symptoms that
are also common with other variants
these include coughing shortness of
breath
fever
muscle aches as well as
loss of smell although this is less
common with the omicron variant omicron
is different than other variants because
of the mutations 32 mutations around the
spike protein itself which means that it
has changed shape and is better able to
enter the cells of the body and
replicate faster replicating 70 times
faster than previous variants and has a
higher ability to reinfect so you're
more likely three to four times more
likely to be reinfected if you've had
previous covet
with the omicron variant overall we also
see that based on early data the
reproduction number is between three to
five the existing vaccines still do help
protect against severe symptoms of
omicron but we are seeing much higher
rates of breakthrough infection with
just two doses which is why it's very
important to get a booster jab as well
with a booster we see that protection
against severe symptoms goes up to 80
percent um compared to the having effect
that we've seen with pfizer just with
two doses alone risk of hospitalization
has decreased with omicron however due
to its increased ability to transmit its
very high transmissibility this means
that we have many more people who are
affected with omicron at the same time
and the growth rate is much higher than
for any other variant that we have seen
before so because it's spreading much
more quickly across the population
many more vulnerable people will all be
sick at the same time so the public
health threat remains because it will
apply a significant amount of pressure
on a health care system so even if delta
had higher rates of hospitalization it
impacted fewer people at the same time
we will see that younger people may have
milder symptoms but those with
underlying conditions and the elderly
will still be at a greater risk of
hospitalization with omicron and can
develop complications this overall if we
look at the advantage that is given by
being milder is essentially cancelled
out by the sheer rate of growth